Automatic patterning on our knitting
machines is almost magical.
Do you remember the first time that you
played with stitch patterning?
I remember crawling under my machine
and looking back to see the results.
But often we make things harder
than they really need to be.
Many a knitter has gotten discouraged
because of all those buttons and levers,
and it just seemed too complex,
complicated and overwhelming.
We're presented with diagrams that look
like this or a bunch of translated
Japanese in a manual
that really isn't clear.
No matter what machine you're using,
there are really only three things
to learn and understand when it
comes to automatic patterning.
Let's consider a manual knitting
machine for just a minute.
In order to create, say,
tuck on a manual machine,
you'll manually pull out some
of the needles all the way and then
set your carriage to hold.
As you push your carriage across,
some needles will form stitches
and other needles won't knit at all.
You'll do this three times and then cancel
hold, knit across and you've
created a series of tuck stitches.
Are you with me?
So two things happened.
Needles were positioned by you and the
carriage was set in a certain way.
Now, let's take this a step further.
The first puzzle piece is the automatic
needle selection mechanism.
Oh, that's a mouthful.
Let's call him OTTO.
We're going to tell him what to do.
Automatic patterning machines have
a mechanism that cuts you out of the loop.
To form stitch patterns.
needles are selected automatically.
How does OTTO know what needles to select?
Well, he isn't really very smart.
He relies on instructions
from punch card or electronics.
Hole / no hole, on/off, black
square/ whitesquare, ones/zeros.
Auto only knows on and off.
Now, once upon a time,
machines had actual mechanical switches
that you could turn on and off
to create stitch patterns.
No matter how you do it,
flipping a switch, reading a punch card or
electronics translates to positioning
the needles as you knit
to the correct position for patterning.
So needle position is
puzzle piece number two.
Now, we don't have to worry too much about
this because OTTO takes care
of the positioning of needles for us.
Moving on the automatic
needle selection mechanism.
OTTO has read the ons and offs and he's
selecting positioning needles for us.
But how does he know what
stitch pattern we want to knit?
As I said, the device isn't really very
smart and it certainly doesn't read minds.
The third piece of the puzzle is
the carriage or cam settings.
It's the carriage that pushes those
needles back and forth,
forming stitches as we knit.
All of the different brands of machines
call these settings something different.
And the buttons and levers are all located
in different places on the carriage.
This gets especially confusing when you
work with different knitting machines.
Now, if you have one machine or multiple
machines,
the secret is to understand the function
of the cam levers or buttons
and their relationship to the other two
puzzle pieces OTTO and needle positions.
Your challenge is to locate
and identify the OTTO on your machine.
Introduce yourself to OTTO and appreciate
the fact that he's keeping track
of the stitch patterns
and pulling needles for you.
Be aware of the different needle
positions and their function.
A-B-C-D-E-F OTTO is going to select
the needles for you and the cam levers
and buttons will control those needles.
But if you have to rip or bind off or
troubleshoot in some way, it's critical
that you understand the needle positions.
Lastly, your challenge is to identify
the specific cam buttons or levers
that control the needle movement
to create specific stitch patterns.
For example, once you have the first two
puzzle pieces in place,
which button or lever do you set to knit
fairisle?
What about tuck? On some of the machines
this is pretty clear.
This clearly tells me
this is my tuck setting.
But part what does that mean?
Maybe there's just a symbol.
You need to translate for yourself
the settings for the different
stitch techniques on your machine.
The very best way to cement these concepts
for yourself is practice and repetition.
Step one meet OTTO. What's
his name on your machine?
Step two understand the needle positions.
ABCDEF, the letter really doesn't matter.
You need to understand what happens
in each of the positions as you knit.
Step three identify and learn each
of the settings for each
of the available stitch techniques.
Tuck, slip, fairisle weaving,
lace, thread lace.
All of the beautiful stitch patterns
we can create automatically.
Understanding the three steps will put you
in the right track for success
with patterning on your
machine with less gray hair.
Happy knitting.